foreign
John Is With Us in Modesto California hi
John how are you
good thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help
so um we took out a HELOC uh last year
uh to make some upgrades around the
house and also to put a practice
baseball field in our backyard
well the HELOC we we under budgeted so
we ran out of the HELOC and we still
need probably another five or six
thousand that get how much did you spend
on your Field of Dreams if you build you
will come
about uh about 40 000 of the HELOC went
towards the ball field about 30 000 went
towards a well and pump that we needed
to put in anyway for our residents
what do you make a year we are I'm sorry
what do you make a year
200 000. between my wife and I okay
and your question is how to come up with
the last five thousand to finish
well yeah we're really hot and heavy in
step two we've already
tackled about 25
000 in debt within the last 30 to 40
days and so how long before how long
before baby step two is done
is there a problem waiting until next
spring to finish the ball field
I mean well tactically technically is
there a problem I'm not talking about
emotionally
yeah yeah that's the big that's the hard
part right um I think we earn about two
thousand dollars per month renting it
out
um but it would take another six
thousand or so to finish it
yeah and each month we have about four
thousand dollars left over from
from income to pay towards who are you
renting a baseball diamond
they are in high demand out here
um it's hard to find fields to practice
on huh
so who's going to pay you like little
kids
whether it's no whether it's a youth a
lot of Youth teams or youth teams pay
two thousand dollars to rent a field no
if I rented out 220 nights a week
100 bucks for a few hours
okay uh if you want to work the cash
flow in to finish it that's fine I have
it's the the first time I've ever taken
a call on a baseball field
I'm
flabbergasted yeah if you build it he
will come and that's what came to mind
I hope this is not I hope your
projections are accurate and you haven't
spent this money
and you've got to get it all paid off
now this goes in the debt snowball by
the way